[Music]
the time where we used to rent videos at
Blockbuster is now over but we can all
remember that at that time it was really
hard to find the movie that we were
looking for that's because they all look
the same and we don't believe that it is
just a coincidence make sure you watch
this video to see how your favorite
movies and TV shows
looks just like each other if you love
movies as much as we do don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we are showing you
ten coincidences in popular culture you
never noticed the big eye this is
probably the most popular movie poster
of all time they say that the eye is the
window to the soul and this is why it
can say a lot of things when we see it
so many times we just want to tell them
that we already got the message it all
started with 2001 a Space Odyssey from
1968 which is probably one of the first
popular movie posters that featured a
big eye and since that day we have just
seen this trend everywhere and it
doesn't seem to stop and horror
filmmakers just seem to love this we see
that a lot when we want to find a good
scary movie to watch for example we have
Chucky Frankenstein's The Texas Chainsaw
Massacre
Candyman The Grudge The Grudge to the
skeleton Keith kilometer 31 the return
the eye godzilla and much more and we
won't forget last known movies like the
day of the jackal deliverance eyes of
Laura Mars when a stranger calls
unforgettable Patrick stung and more it
was so associated with horror films that
we were surprised to see a big eye
featured in posters for movies like
dinosaur or avatar but no matter what we
are always surprised to see how they all
use something similar and found a way to
make it look really different each time
hey guys we are so excited to announce
we are producing our own original
content head over to the trendy for the
best DIYs fashion tips makeup acts and
so much more we are sure you're going to
love it
and be sure to let us know what you
think in the comment section we love to
hear from you the red dress red is the
color of love and passion studies have
even shown that women look more
attractive when they are wearing
something red or even just standing in
front of a red background this is
probably one of the reasons why we see a
lot of red dresses on movie posters for
a romantic comedy or if the film is not
really funny you can at least be sure
that a femme Sekou will be wearing that
beautiful dress to get all the attention
that she deserves when we talk about
romantic comedies we think about movies
like the ugly truth last holiday the
rebound she's out of my league what's
your number
about time Moulin Rouge and more we have
seen it for a long time since movies
like the woman in red a fair in Trinidad
river of no return and more but we were
also surprised to see this red dress on
horror movie posters or psychological
thrillers like Carrie
Dark Shadows when the bough breaks
Resident Evil Jennifer's Body and more
so we won't forget movies like Anna
Karenina Tutsi gangster squad dressmaker
me before you and more these red dresses
are just everywhere no matter what the
actress is all look stunning in these
beautiful dresses if it still works
there is no reason why they should stop
doing it we bet that you can name even
more movies than this big faces over the
beach this thing is so specific that we
can't believe that so many poster
designers did the same thing but no
matter what we just keep seeing big
faces in the sky over tiny people on the
beach we guess that this is a way to
feel closer to the character while
feeling that they are just people like
us in this big universe we have seen
this before so maybe it is time to try
something new you have probably seen it
before on posters for popular movies
like the last song and Charlie st. cloud
but if you pay attention to other movies
you will see that turning green fugitive
pieces Sara's key two weeks closed for
the winter up-close-and-personal Captain
Corelli's Mandolin and tomorrow is today
are doing the same thing do you want to
see even more we also saw big people
over the beach in goal foreveryoung moon
dance Alex
surviving Picasso all the Pretty Horses
walk on water
Dwayne hop with City of Angels and
probably more but it's not just in
English people all around the world have
been doing this with movie titles in
different languages there is just
something about this theme that people
want to recreate again and again and we
won't believe that it is just a
coincidence after people did it so many
times people standing back-to-back how
can we show that two people are in a
kind of love-hate relationship if you
are like any of these filmmakers you
would probably want to make the two main
characters stand back-to-back on the
picture it is a great way to show that
they are actually close to each other
even if they don't want the same thing
we see that a lot with romantic comedies
like pretty woman Four Christmases Run
Fatboy Run How to Lose a Guy in 10 days
ghosts of Girlfriends Past two weeks
notice kiss and kill no reservations and
more it's just the same thing over and
over again oh we won't forget other
comedies links to game plan Bride Wars
my girl ice princess and more even
movies from all around the world like
these films in French love to see their
heroes back-to-back viewed from the side
we can also see people standing
back-to-back in action movies like wild
target or double zero but we guess that
this kind of relationship is so funny
that we'd rather see it in comedies at
least there is one good thing to say
about that
as soon as we see this kind of poster we
know what to expect from the film and as
most of them were really good we know
that we'll have fun watching it the
loner viewed from behind don't think
that only comedies or horror films are
all the same when we were looking for an
action movie or some drama we can see a
lot of similar posters one of the most
popular is probably the loner viewed
from behind it is a good way to show
that he is mysterious and make us season
as it's going to be him against the
world in the movie we have to admit that
it works but it doesn't have the same
impact after we see it too many times we
saw this on movie posters for films like
d'Artagnan Puss in Boots V for Vendetta
shoot him up and the warrior way wait
there is even
more we can also see the same thing for
movies like Blade Picher The Sorcerer's
Apprentice anonymous walk the line
kick-ass Harry Potter Watchmen Fifty
Shades of Grey and more we also love to
see strong women on movie posters for
films like Resident Evil extinction and
GI Joe who would just like to see more
of them it's sad that we could only
think of two don't you think that women
deserve a more important role in action
movies don't be shy to tell us what you
think in the comments section down below
we love to hear what you think
building a face we think that this one
is a really interesting movie poster you
use an object or pictures to recreate a
face and it creates an amazing picture
with a lot of meaning this one wasn't
used too many times but just enough so
we could see that this was clearly not a
coincidence but no matter what they
always found a way to create something
new and make sure that their movie
poster would stand out from the others
for example The Truman Show used a lot
of pictures to recreate the movie poster
because the hero was being filmed all
the time as he was part of a reality
show in Premonition the trees were
trying to show us a sign
in shrooms a skull was made with
mushrooms and in Religulous the grilled
cheese reminded us of people who thought
they saw the face of Jesus on their
toast as if it was a sign from God and
these are not the only movies who did
that we could also see creators building
a face with objects for films like the
next three days Lord of war Rambo The
Prestige the descent white-noise cabin
fever and the dark night no matter what
we have to admit that they found a
really good way to turn something so
similar into something really unique so
between the leg shots it is time to get
a little wild with a lot of movies that
are usually for grown-ups if you can see
something between the legs of a woman
you know that this movie is probably not
going to be appropriate for kids but
don't worry you should usually have the
right to see the movie poster even if
you are not old enough not so
surprisingly we often see the legs of a
beautiful woman and not the legs of a
man that's a way to tell us that this
movie is going to focus on something
that happens between the legs of a woman
grown-ups will know what we are talking
about anyway a lot of movies have been
doing this some of these movies were
Austin Powers goldmember's kids in
America
Corporate Affairs illegally yours New
York taxis doghouse singer and super
troopers if that's not enough for you
you'll also have to watch popped three
bad sisters kinky boots naked Tomcats
only too lonely for your eyes only Chuck
and much more we've told you that these
movies were not appropriate for kids so
you were warned but don't worry girls it
is also possible to see between the leg
shots of guys that you like you just
need to do more research to find it but
we know that they are there in bed
usually people sleep together because
they are happy to be with each other but
when things go bad they are stuck
together in the same bed then this is
when things get really awkward this is
probably why filmmakers want to capture
this moment and it is such a great way
to represent a complicated relationships
but it often ends up on the movie poster
we think that it is a great idea but
unfortunately the more you use an idea
the more it becomes a cliche and people
don't necessarily like that that doesn't
keep us from seeing people in bed on
movie posters again and again only to
name a few we have it's complicated
license to Wed the break-up a single man
sleeping dogs lie all good things and
more can you believe that there are even
more movie posters we can also show you
hump day maybe baby I don't want to
sleep alone match point
bedtime for Bonzo bag head and the
four-faced liar and there are still so
many movies that we don't know because
they are in different languages it might
be a cliche but even though the movie is
really similar to what we have already
seen before we know that it is going to
be fun why would they do something
different when they already know that
showing people in bed works as long as
they find new ways to make it special
there is nothing wrong with that
Tom Cruise is best profile we think that
this one is really fun because not only
the filmmakers did the same thing but
the actor too
it looks like Tom Cruise really does
have a best profile because he always
does the same thing on each movie poster
there's nothing wrong with that because
he really does look handsome but it is
still fun to see that just look at
Mission Impossible Mission Impossible -
Mission Impossible 3
Jerry Maguire collaterals
days days of thunder eyes wide shut and
legend the actor clearly found one good
way to pose when he keeps doing the same
thing it works after all so why would he
change but don't worry he is not always
doing the same thing just take for
example Top Gun risky business
oblivion Rain Man Vanilla Sky and The
Last Samurai
it feels good to finally see different
movie posters but there are too many
posters of Tom Cruise's sets profile for
it to be a coincidence
do you think that Tom Cruise knows about
this we bet that he was the first one to
find out about this when he looked at
his movie collection we hope that it
made him smile as much as we do or maybe
that's also why he tried to do something
else for the next photoshoot and more
there are a lot of movie and TV posters
that look like something else even
though there are not a lot of posters
that look the same but they are so
popular that we immediately notice it
for example we could see two people
making out in a car on the popular TV
show Riverdale does that remind you of
something we've already seen it before
in it follows we also think this movie
poster for Star Wars The Force awakens
looks really similar to the poster for
stranger things so light is right on the
left and blue on the right the
characters are in the same position and
even the modifications make the pictures
look the same the posters for Captain
America Civil War and neighbors to
Sorority rising are also really similar
people have even been arguing on which
one was the best
send there's future sport that look just
like Speer and we also noticed that
Jason and prom night looked really
similar and these are only a few of all
the movie posters that we could name but
we want you to show us what we have been
missing did you notice any other
coincidences in popular culture don't be
shy to tell us what it was in the
comment section down below
we love to know what you think and
that's it for 10 coincidences in popular
culture you never notice for more
stories like this make sure you watch 10
the loud house fan theories that will
blow your mind
thanks for watching
[Music]